and the Oscar goes to to every women who
gave birth to every taxpayer and citizen
of this nation it's our time to have
wage equality once and for all and equal
rights for women in the United States of
America for my fellow Mexicans I pray
that we can find and build the
government that we deserve and the ones
that live in this country us pray that
they can be treated with the same
dignity and respect of the ones who came
before and build this incredible
immigrant nation the disclosures that
Edward Snowden reveals don't only expose
a threat to our privacy but to our
democracy itself when the most important
decisions being made affect affecting
all of us are made in secret we live in
the most incarcerated country in the
world there are more black men under
correctional control today than were
under slavery in 1850